mon
oui
[Musique]
nous
neil est ce que pouvez-vous présenter
déjà pour commencer
alors du coup je m'appelle gilles vilard
et
j'ai grandi en suisse et je vis en
suisse j'ai toujours été dans les forêts
du jura dans lesquelles j'ai fait de la
photographie
j'ai commencé par un apprentissage de
forestiers bûcherons
ensuite j'ai entrepris des études de la
beauronne biologie où j'ai continué de
travailler maintenant à l'université de
neuchâtel comme la mort en biologie et
j'ai un temps partagé entre la photo et
mon travail à l'université et aussi je
travaille pas mal comme père au foyer
la première question aller simple est ce
que vous vous souvenez de votre première
rencontre avec un lynx
alors ça c'est sûr ma première rencontre
avec un axe elle s'est pas passé par
hasard ça a été je vais revenir vraiment
en arrière depuis tout petit c'est un
rêve de voir si j'ai fréquenté ces
forêts depuis vraiment les premiers
souvenirs est arrivé à mes 21 ans
j'étais vraiment frustré de pas avoir vu
cette bête qui me faisait tant rêver
donc j'ai entrepris de voir cette bête
de tout faire pour pouvoir voir cette
bête et là à partir de là il m'a fallu
trois ans pour la voir et de fil en
aiguille j'ai trouvé de plus en plus d'
indice ça m'a amené à une rencontre mais
une rencontre qui était vraiment
vraiment misérable parce que j'ai un ami
qui était avec moi qui est venu une fois
au lynx avec moi d'ailleurs et 15
minutes après ils tombent dessus par
hasard
et moi j'étais sur le chemin il m'a
appelé et m'a dit viens viens vite il
est là et là du coup je suis cool comme
un fou pendant plusieurs kilomètres pour
arriver jusqu'à lui
quand je suis arrivé vers lui il m'a dit
vrai il est monté il est monté il est là
haut et dans les rochers bon moi je vais
essayer de voir
j'arrive à monter ont déroché les
rochers qu'il a fallu 40 45 secondes
loin que ça monte et moi il m'a fallu 40
45 minutes et à partir de dès que
j'arrivais sur les rochers je n'ai
aperçu était couchée tranquille posée
mais vraiment pas couverts il a été dans
les buts dans des buissons gelé à peine
vu à peine entraperçu et dès qu'il a vu
que j'avais vues et s'est levé et les
parties c'était impossible de suivre
déjà classe n'est pas facile de
le suivre j'ai pas pu faire de photos
j'ai à peine pu l'entrevoir j'étais
essoufflé j'étais fatigué et l'a jetée
là ok maintenant je veux vraiment le
voir comme il faut j'ai repris ma
maquette et marais fallu trois ans pour
le voir elle photographie comme il faut
et à partir de là j'ai commencé
le début de mes projets vous êtes en
train de me dire que au moment où vous
voulez voir un lynx il vous faut six ans
pour y arriver vraiment pour le
photographier et d'être pour avoir une
belle image de lynx m'a fallu six ans et
surgelés en hd entraperçu entre temps
mais pour vraiment faire une belle image
m'a fallu six ans depuis le moment où
j'ai commencé à travailler dessus
jusqu'à ce que je le fasse mais tu es ce
qu'il à cet animal qui vous fascine tant
pour moi le lynx c'est plus qu'un animal
c'est plus quelque chose de deux
légendaires de mystérieux jeu là je le
compare un peu à la vivre qu'on aurait
dans le jura par exemple quelque chose
qui est vraiment qui existe pas mais qui
baigne avec son aura en fait l'ambiance
d'une forêt l'ambiance de la nature et
depuis tout petit à chaque fois que je
me balade dans les forêts qui pourrait
accueillir un axe j'ai l'impression de
pouvoir l'apercevoir
derrière chaque tronc derrière chaque
rocher le voir sur chaque crête
c'est vraiment un animal qui m'a hanté
qui m'a fasciné et qui vous obsède cd
exactement parce que du coup derrière
vous on en a un très bel exemple on
pense à quoi quand on voit dans son
objectif cet animal vous regardez un peu
comme celui qui est derrière vous là on
imagine qu'ils vous regardent alors la
photo qui est derrière moi
oui me regarde plus ce qu'ils me
regardent pas ce qu'en fait j'ai même
pas d'affût et sur cette photo là qui
est probablement la meilleure rencontre
j'ai fait avec un lynx c'est elle qui
est venue vers moi en fait à une
distance à une distance vraiment
déconcertante de moins de 3 mètres à
l'ail à moins de trois mètres entre vous
là sur la photo non mais elle a fini sa
course à moins de trois mètres
cela dit c'est la distance d'autofocus
de mon objectif qui est trois mètres 60
est largement venue au delà de ça je me
demandais pourquoi elle vient autant
prêt et ça a été vraiment quelque chose
de très particulier vu que c'est elle
qui a entrepris cette approche
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
dans ses yeux la curiosité pas du tout
l'animosité ou la peur elle est belle
cette photo pour ça aussi
non le chai de langue c
c'est vraiment important de comprendre
que l'animal qui absolument pas agressif
comme on pourrait voir je suis sur
d'autres d'autres grands félins
c'est pas un animal qui est territoriale
qui va avoir un comportement mauvais en
virant vers l'être humain il n'y a aucun
risque j'ai déjà d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
rencontré le lynx à une distance très
faible en train de manger
j'avais mes deux enfants avec des
enfants en bas âge qui avaient une année
et demi et trois ans et même à aucun
moment j'aurais pu imaginer que mes
enfants étaient en danger
ça vous procure quoi ces moments c'est
quelque chose de fantastique qui est
relié aux côtés société qu'on a actuelle
est aux côtés un peu ancestrales
alors déjà c'est quelque chose qu'il dit
au pistage c1 c'est un instinct qui est
puissant de piste est un prédateur de se
suivre de pouvoir comprendre ce qui fait
de lire avec ses traces ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a fait durant la journée ou la
nuit
et ensuite l'autre côté qui est vraiment
intéressant avec
avec ses rencontres avec le sauvage
c'est non qu'est ce qui vous intéresse
alors en plus le fait de le traquer et
puis après c'est un jeu en fait entre
lui et vous parce que oui ce qui vous
sont justement vous arrivez à le
photographier parce qu'il n'a pas vu et
vous avez gagné entre guillemets ce nom
alors le lynx
il sait toujours que je suis là peu
importe la situation
souvent c'est à lapproche donc j'ai pas
de camouflage et rien du tout j'ai pas
d'artifices qui me permettent de me
cacher et là c'est assez simple parce
qu'en fait dès qu'il a accepté que je
sois là je peux me permettre de bouger
de le suivre
selon c'est tolérance je connais très
bien les individus que je suis donc je
sais aussi sur quel individu je peux me
permettre
quel comportement est autrement quand je
suis à l'affût même le mieux cacher
possible il ya toujours la lentille qui
est visible et à ce moment là
lui il est toujours conscient en fait de
ma présence il y connaît tellement bien
son territoire il a tellement aquantive
house éléments de son immeuble de son
environnement que il est toujours au
courant de ce qui se passe en fait que
j'ai pas encore compris c'est savoir si
vous étiez un photographe qui était
tombé amoureux des animaux si vous étiez
un amoureux des animaux et que vous êtes
devenu photographe pour les
photographier alors en fait c'est un peu
compliqué les deux en même temps j'ai
aucun souvenir de ma vie de ne pas avoir
fait de photos ou de ne pas avoir été
naturaliste en fait j'ai grandi dans ce
milieu et vivre en forêt c'est ma vie
j'ai connu rien d'autre que de forts que
ça et c'est vraiment le l'élément clé de
la personne que je suis maintenant dans
l' ouvrage lynx une ombre en lumière que
vous vous sortez il ya bien sûr beaucoup
de photos de lynx mais il ya aussi les
photos de tous les autres animaux que
vous croisez mais le lynx il au dessus
du lot je dirais pas qu'il est au dessus
du lot par rapport à moi oui parce que
c'est un grand prédateur et je suis
vraiment fasciné par les grands
prédateurs surtout pas la place qu'ils
occupent la relation avec la vie
elle-même enfin le même le sens de la
vie que ça c'est un peu compliqué
que les prédateurs c'est l'entité même
du nature en fête du sauvage et la
relation avec le lynx c'est pas une
préférence pour le lynx ou pour pour un
autre animal c'est vraiment celui qui me
fait vibrer par contre je vois la
portance quand je suis à l'affût j'ai
toujours du plaisir un plaisir énorme à
contempler ne serait ce que des merles
j'adore le merle qui signifie la fin la
fin de la journée qui va qui va qui va
chanter les derniers moments des lueurs
enfin le crépuscule qui arrive
j'adore voir l'écureuil qui va chercher
ses provisions
j'aime vraiment voir toute la faune mais
le lynx c'est vraiment ce qui me fait
plus vibrer à cause de ses relations
primitif hommes prédateurs vous savez
combien vous avez pris de photos de lynx
n'ont aucune idée
vous savez combien vous aimez de photos
de lynx mais vous et moi j'ai mis une
photo
combien vous en avez réussi de bonnes en
fait un jeu serait prétentieux je les
aime toutes à leur façon parce que
chaque rencontre signifiant moment très
important dans ma vie même s'il ya eu un
grand nombre de rencontres
il ya un grand nombre de moments
nature qui est incroyable c'est à dire
que là demain vous photographier un lynx
en forêt vous aurez le même plaisir
qu'au début alors sur la photographie
non sur la rencontre hui d'ailleurs mon
prochain but maintenant que j'ai plus la
pression de la photographie vu que j'ai
fini mes deux projets sur le lynx
j'ai envie de pouvoir observer le lynx
d'une manière différente honnêtement les
prochaines fois que j'ai envie des prêts
d'observer le lynx c'est d'un point de
vue uniquement naturaliste y prendre mes
jumelles et contempler l'animal sans me
poser la question sur des réglages
matériel sur me dire ça va être une
belle image sympa très bonne image
j'ai juste envie de vivre un moment
intense et puissant avec cet animal sans
avoir quoi que ce soit d'autre à vivre
derrière on va faire un peu un point
technique maintenant oui comment est-ce
qu'on photographier un lynx qu'un
appareil photo
mais pour ça ce qu'il faut c'est c'est
déjà bien connaître son matériel photo
c'est super important parce qu'une
rencontre avec un prédateur avec le lynx
en particulier surtout comme ça fait
longtemps qu'on travaille sur le sujet
c'est toujours des moments qui sont
assez déconcertant surtout au début
donc on a peur de faire tous les
réglages en campagne et qu on appelle à
se concentrer sur ce qu'on va faire donc
c'est important de bien connaître son
matériel et après de pouvoir quand même
vivre là la rencontre
si j'aurai un conseil à donner à
quelqu'un c'est six voix lynx s'il n'est
pas capable de photographier par ces
conditions sont difficiles ses positions
matérielles et vivre ce moment parce que
c'est un moment unique que beaucoup de
naturalistes rêve de vivre et il faut
vraiment savoir profiter de ces moments
là c'est à dire peut-être aussi être
avec un autofocus ne pas s'occuper de la
lumière mais juste capter l'instant le
plus simplement possible pour ne pas
perdre de l'énergie et du temps à avec
ça alors je dirais que c'est pas aussi
simple que ça parce que malheureusement
l'un qui se présentent rarement dans des
conditions parfaites de lumière et tout
donc il ya souvent pas mal d'ajustements
à faire pour faire une pour sortir une
belle image si on veut faire une image
souvenir c'est pas un problème mais pour
une belle image qui soit techniquement
propre
il ya quand même pas mal de
deux techniques à connaître et à mettre
en oeuvre sans devoir réfléchir c'est
vraiment un entraînement tous les jours
de pouvoir maîtriser son matériel
maîtriser la photo et saisir ces
instants après c'est pas un animal qu'on
imagine comme étant très furtif mais il
faut quand même ça va très vite pour
capter le moment alors non c'est plutôt
le contraire c'est un animal très furtif
mais une fois qu'on a réussi à localiser
si on sait ce qu'on porte me comporter
comme il faut avec avec l'animal ont pu
vivre des moments intenses et surtout
pas vivre longtemps
au début je panique un peu je vais un
peu c'est un peu anarchique de la façon
dont je prends un cd quand je le voyais
ça dure est assez peu de temps
maintenant je sais profiter de ces
moments et les exploiter au mieux et ça
m'arrive des fois maintenant de passer
plus d'une demi journée complète avec
l'animal sur lequel je suis je suis
focalisé nil est ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être un peu privilégié
d'avoir vécu ces moments là avec ces
animaux est ce que vous voyez d'un bon
oeil le fait que de plus en plus de gens
peut-être aille aussi en forêt pour
essayer de capter ce moment là alors je
me sens privilégié oui et non je me sens
privilégié parce que j'ai grandi dans
cette région ça m'a permis de la
connaître sur le bout de mes doigts ça
et ça a contribué énormément à la
réussite de mes deux projets de livres
par contre après pour la deuxième
question si ça me pose problème ça je
trouve ça chouette que les gens aient
envie de voir le lynx c'est oui et non
oui c'est intéressant parce que c'est
chouette parce que les gens peuvent
vivre quelque chose de fort dans leur
vie quelque chose de magnifique parce
qu'en fait c'est quelque chose qui est
pas payable c'est pas parce qu'on a une
grosse bourse on peut se payer leur
encontre et que le lynx et ça c'est
fantastique vraiment pouvoir imaginer
que juste comme ça maintenant dans ce
monde maintenant et l'autre aspect c'est
m
combien de personnes vont respecter
l'animal vous respectez les zones
il ya énormément de choses à respecter
quand on suit un animal aussi aussi
fragile parce que derrière cet aspect de
bêtes
deux bêtes de prédateurs qui a l'air
très robuste il ya un aspect très
fragile de son de sa vie secrète il a
besoin de tranquillité et autant sur des
zones comme on le voit filmé au
téléphone portable c'est qu'il a accepté
de se montrer ou ce qui n'est pas
discret il n'y a pas de problème mais
les gîtes d'urnes les endroits il va
passer la journée les endroits où il va
se cacher où il va il va à l'été ces
petits durant l'été où il va aller à
mener c'est petit pour ce pour se
reposer durant la journée où elle est où
ils vont aller se reproduire avec sa
femelle si c'est un mâle tous ces
moments sont des zones ont des moments
qui sont très très important peu à être
discrets à être cachés et ça ça doit
être respectée et pour faire des belles
images de lynx il faut forcément
respecter l'animal on peut pas on peut
faire une image de lynx comme ça par
hasard
mais si on veut vraiment réussir à
travailler sur ce thème allez vous
vraiment respectée c'est comme pour tous
les sujets et ce respect c'est la clé
primordial la photographie animalière
même mais avec le lynx c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce qu'on a vraiment aspects
de vouloir absolument le voir et vous
arrivez d'être dans des spots qui était
devenu trop touristique entre guillemets
non parce que là où je veille à personne
cette fleur de peau alors non parce que
toute façon les gens ils pourraient
passer des centaines de jours à l'affût
et ne verrait rien du tout j'adapte
chaque jour de terrain j'adapte mon
terrain par rapport à là où je vais ou
pas
et je travaille le plus proche possible
de chez moi parce que chaque minute
passée dans la voiture c'est dix minutes
son temps passé sur le terrain et chaque
minute sur le terrain compte parce que
mis bout à bout
après à la fin du mois on arrive à des
oeuvres c'est colossal le ton peut
passer dans la voiture si on fait pas
attention à ça dernière question est ce
qu'un animal que vous rêvez de
photographier ou beaucoup beaucoup ce
serait difficile les grands prédateurs
en général sans avoir vraiment but
maintenant précis oui parce que c'est ça
en fait le lynx et le grand prédateur de
nos contrées en fait exactement